Hello, everybody, My name is Markiplier
And welcome to Yet Another Exhausting Day
Or, Yet Another Day Exhausting Prototype
As it says on the title there.
Imagine that you're coming home from work
Or you're just waking up
And the entirety of life is just a burden upon your soul.
You can't be bothered to do any shit
You can't be bothered to put any energy into any activity
that you have planned for that day
You are just a human slug
Trying to slide your way out of bed and
and through life so that you can eventually make it back into bed (To Relateable)
That's who you are in this game.
That's what this game represents, as far as I know.
And I can relate to that very heavily, and I'm pretty sure that many of you
can relate to that, oh, God,
you are to jiggly for my, tastes. *yum*
Hello
As a young professional with a promising future
My life in the city is overwhelmingly tiring.
Yea, me too, buddy.
me too *poor mark*
I am exhausted *in funny accent*
Yea, me too buddy.
So waddaya gonna do about it
ha, you gonna get- Yet I can not slEEp
Maybe it's all the energy drinks you crammed down your gullet.
Maybe you think about that every once in a while?
*giggle*
*More intense giggling turning into laughter*
This is what I was hoping for
*Hughhh*(Wut..)
*ughh* *more giggling* (Mark U, K?)
*laughter* (Should I call somebody?)
Yea, this is, is - *laughter* this is how the game's controlled
*hughhh* Oh MY GOD *while laughing*
What did I do??!
Sense lessens in time, causing you to fall asleep
okay, HABOOSKEY *laughs*
HABOOSKEY!!!!
lemmie just pelvic thrust into the grou- whoahhh *laughs*
Im not doing th- what am I doing?
what the fuck am I doing?
*small chuckle*
*laughs again*
*laughs*
I'm gonna get this eventually I don't know what I'm doing
hang on- wait, oh, boos.
kay, here we go, I'm really scooching my tooch
scoochey toosh
thare we go, thas good
okay, sense increases from external stimulation
okay, like what?
oh, whelp, there I go *chuckling*
*laughs*
alright okay, here we go
ugh, ok- im not
okay, if you barely even move it- o, ow *laughs*
by external simulation, you man cramming my head into the nearest objects?
*eugh*
no!
alright
I'm gonna roll for it.
I'm rolling for initiative
I think this is what they call twerking, ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) but I'm not 100 percent sure.
Okay, lets try- I'm guess I'm going up this wall?
yes I am *while laughing*
*heyuh* *laughing*
Caffeine will offer a short - i'm, i'm in the ground *laughing*
AAAAAHHHHHHH
okay, I think we're free
hehhh ehhh
oh my god *laughing* ughhhh
oh *laughing*
oh geez, this is the greatest thing.
Here I go. He is beauty, he is grace.
He will slide upon his face.
What a beautiful man.
Oh *laughing* can I go get this caffeine?
It's just this god damn snake man
This is the greatest game, you know this if the kind of uh..
This is the kind of innovation the gaming industry needed.
exCUSE me, I didn't expect to go that way
I'm sorry.
*heyugh* *laughing*
this is- I just, I just imagine this man
slamming his testicles into the ground as hard as he can *laughing*
it's a- oh, shit.
oh, ohh *laughing*
oh, okay, pillows are naptime death
so I've been
OH COME ON I just barely touched it
Habooskey
okay, OH COME ON are you magnetized to the god damn pillow?
Is there Velcro on his head? Stupid idiot
Habooskey
HAbooskey get up there re- OW
nonono DON'T ROLL
hugh OWWW
OOWWW
can you not, oww
OWWW  I really knocked some sense into- Uh oh.
okay, were okay.
Just get outta here.
there we go.
THATS WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT x2
this is a good game, this is a good game.
no DONT ROLL. What?
what was even the point of rolling?
why would you wanna roll?
oh, that's gonna go to far.
oh, smar- smart man
Smart man I am. Smart man I am, go up the sides
so my head can't hit it.
oh, I am so goddamn smart.
oh, go go go go go GO GOOO
I don't care, go.
na, na, na, na. You're fine.
n- yeaa you're fine buddy. you're fine
this is, the is the goddamn gratest game.
AH! After finishing a page of Murakami, I post an update sharing my wisdom of living offline.
oh. oh, okay, good.that's great.
oh. My head becomes heavier. *laughter* Yea, welcome to my world.
my, my heavy ass head.
no don- don't roll. why are you rolling??
WHY??!
what is the point of rolling?
theres no point, i- WHY CANT THERE BE A SEPERATE BUTTON??
alright, i'm gonna wait my by time.
im really gonna get it.
HABOOSKEY
yeaa
AH! oh f- fuck
I got eaten by the pillow.
well how am I supposta- whoaaaaa
alright then, well I guess
this is what we're dealing with.
maybe if I go ass first into the pillow it won't be so bad.
no don't roll, DONT
*marks utter disappointment*
why arn't you just goddamn sweet pee?
how bout you just listen to my fuckin' words, why don't cha
Maybe that's what I need to do. Maybe rolling is the answer.
'kay imma try a roll.
here we go, roll, no, this Is- NO you stop. why- what WHAT ARE YOU DOING?!?!
everyone can see my mouse, everyone knows youre fucking stupid.
oww *turns into laughter*
he knocked himself out real good with that one.
sure. we're gonna go with a big ol' SURE
no, n- no no. n- no NO NOOOOO *mating call*
This is impossible. *laughter*
this is fucking impossible, how would anybody do this? You can't do this.
it's impossible.
okay, well then that's just stupid.
*heavy sigh*
its like as soon as I touch it,  I barely touch it and its like a ffffucking recoil.
get my head OUT of the way.
im going to slide my head back, okay, no im going to do THIS apparently
c- go go GO GOO GOD FUCKING DUCKA DAMMIT
fuck a duck a damn WHAT THE FUCK
*poor mark.*
nooAAAA
you suck tits
you piece of shit, you garbage human, you garbage human.
GARBAGE HUMAN
even though I relate extremely heavily, just, youre REALLY messing up my steeze right now.
okay, alright. Progress.
get my head out of the way. NO no no no.
get my head-
no, okay, this is bad, this is bad, this is bad, this is bad, this is bad
no
NOOO *bye bye pot.*
za- NO WHAT ARE YOU DOING
STOP IT. just stop
okay. keep it in the leaves.
Smell the leaves real hard.
Sniff those leaves.
what we're going to do, were going to break for it. When we get an opportunity.
were going to really douche for it.
eugh
there we go. YES
YES
that was fucking impossible
what was that so hard?
ah, crazy dog. Perfect.
exactly what I needed.
oh yea.
of that dwoof *laughs*
excuse me while I hang onto this ledge  by my nose
BOINK
ah, good shit, good shit indeed.
alright, so we just gotta skate right by these things
'scuse me light.
oh yeah, easy peasy.
easy breezy. beautiful me, *yes you are beautiful, mark*
oh, whaat??
oh boy, i'm just so boned.
okay, im just dead, alright, so I gotta ram my head into the nearest object.
as fast as I humanly can. Oh, Shit.
go for it!
RAM BABY Don't you run away from me.
hehehehe
gottem
no no NOOOOO you ID- you ADDICT
You sleep addict. Just get away from me. You don't even have to touch it.
You don't even have to do anything to it. Just don't do nothing.
Stupid piece of shit, you rolley bastard.
You fucking roley poley here!
Why do you wanna roll so badly?
There's just no reason to. No, don't roll.
uughhhh
Let's try to go for this guy.
coming in for- NOOOOOO
OOh
im so mayud
Alright, here we go. I'm going to come in for a landing.
*CLUNK*
*CLUNK* (I would be sleeping forever after that hit)
Okay and then WERE GONNA GET OUR HEAD OUT OF HERE  ooo OHO
alright, now im getting it. now im getting the rhythm.
I think I could have just gunned for this right off the bat.
i gues i didn't really need to wait for anything but OH WELL.
here we go, easy peasy, lemon squeez
OH WORK TIME, yes pwease. I guess I gotta ram my- Oh shit, I guess I gotta ram my head (How mark does vids ^)
*giggle* let me just do this by my nose.
You are a warrior now. Let the adventure begin! I calmly embark in my darkest journey.
why? thas was- that's bizzare
I'm playing D&D
My head becomes heavier. Yet I cannot sleep
I can't. it's Impossible.
Im from the Russian- Oh god, OH MY GOD
ohh hoo
aghh
EVERYTHING IS PAIN
OH, OH, OH, oh, that's not right.
that's no- OH HI
*giggling* what the fuck was that?
I was so busy paying attention to my roley poley self that I didn't notice the fucking ROOMBA
uh oh. no, okay.
BONK
ookay, what the fuck.
I'm going to give a big old, yea right to that one.
there is no way that worked.
no DONT roll.
okay, just go for it. ugh my god
Why does this Roomba have a vendetta against me?
and since when can a Roomba fluff a pillow for me?
alright whatever. I'm going for that mad dog.
you can't stop me.
Brev.
try me.
missed me. Bitch.
no.Don't roll.
Fucking asshole.
kay, there is not point of rolling.
the only reason that rolling exists, is to get in the way.
which I think is a fascinating game mechanic itself.
Like you're so tired, I cant help myself but todo 360's in my snooze
Like, it's such a stupid mechanic. It doesn't work. It doesn't do anything.
ugh just barely get my nose in the- Oh boy.
nooOOoo
missed me.
missed me. bet you wanna kiss me.
uh oh.
I wanna g- oh shit.
no gah! right to it OH OHHHHAAAAGH
you were not right to it and then you went right to something else.
you fuCkiNg aSsHoLe.
It's like I have the most simple of re- Glass in the eye. Yea, that'll wake me up.
I feel great now, fuck yea, man.
roley pol- okay, why nooOOOO
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?!!??
WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT MANEUVER??!?!?
WHAT DID YOU JUST DO?
HOW DID YOU BREAK PHYSICS?
I mean you're on the wall so I guess you already are breaking physics, but what the hell, man, okay.
wait, how, wait, wait.
wait.
roley poley?
ooh my god
i, get- stand on your legs, man, stand on your legs.
h- you can't-
this is impossible. well,
fuck me
well that's impossible.
there's no way
*marks utter confusion*
what??
oooohhhhh
that got rid of that pillow.
but that didn't do anything for me.
so there's something to breaking glass
and that helpin in some wa- o, okay, goodbue
well, he looks a little concerned.
huh.
you have- you have no purpose anymore
so you're just drifting aimlessly?
I'm so sorry, me too, man. OOW what the fuck *as he continues to do it*
okay..?
y- you're terrified, man.
OH MY GOD
I am so sorry
I did not know the powers inside my soul.
I think what I have to do is I have to blow that guy up here. *heheh*
so I gotta- I gotta like
I think I just gotta
I gotta fucking ram him.
I think that's all I gotta do, right?
so imma just g- I'm gonna charge this bastard
You think you can get away from me? huh?
you think you can got me?
HUH?
oh shit you do not- oh get fuuucked
no, don't roll.
oh shit. OH
okay, well, that didn't work out, BUT the idea is there
well maybe i gotta g- make him afraid?
cause he ran away from me
so that muse be a thing. so, if i get these, that one goes away,
and there he goes, h- he- now he's running away from me. EUGHH
no no, AHH SHIT GOD D- ooh
okay I gotta get behind him.
He's gonna back away from me, right?
okay, goo
no go, *sigh*
*KABLAMMO* Hmmm
why does he just back up, why does he do this?
Why does he only go to this corner?
OH Caffeine gives me immunity OOOH that i- that makes a lot more sense than i was trying to do.
okay, well I'm just a big dumb dummy. *nooo you aren't*
after 15 pushups, I ordered half a fried chicken. Imagine all the muscle I will gain in a month. I laugh.
oh,
okay, what is your life? Are you one punch man? *yes*
OH is it time?
Is it finally time for snoozeville?
PLEASE
PLEASE LET IT BE TIME
AAH
sweet, sweet slumber.
AAh
there we are.
*sigh* finally.
the sweet embrace of sleep.
oh, cutscene
at last, there is still a long time before tomorrow
having squeezes every drop from my day, I giggled like a big baby
*Mark imitating what a maniacal laughing baby would sound like*
a tired heart has found peace. I can finally rest my eyes.
*Mark imitating what a maniacal laughing baby would sound like once again*
you know, a big baby.
It's like a big baby, you know. Me.
AWWW
That was nice.
I got stuck 'cause I was Stoopid.
But that was really nice.
That was really, really nice.
I liked that.
aww what a cutie.
So, that was Yet Another Exhausting Day. I think we can all relate to this one
In one way or another, especially down to the worm, slug-like method of transportation.
So, thank you again, let me know if you have other weird games that you want me to play
down in the comments below. AND if you want to help me make cool stuff
Click the big "Join" button, see all the perks you get
For supporting the channel.
Thank you everybody so much, and as always,
I will see YOU in the next video.
BUH BYE
*outro music*
Y U STILL Here!? Watch More Mark!